hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
soeben ein neues bild auf instagram
hochgeladen also schaut gerne mal vorbei
und kommentierte dass ich aussehe wie
ein mülleimer spaß beiseite freunde ich
darf euch heute mal wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen episode mord sales mit luca bzw
heute sind es eigentlich mehr mutter
whatsapp fällt weil fast jeder fehlt
irgendwie von der mama kommt daten also
direkt mit diesem chat verlauf und zwar
schreibt die mutter heute abend schon
was geplant so lusa das ist 100
prozentig leider nicht meine mutter beim
nächsten woche empfehlen ist eine mutter
übers wochenende verreist und hat ihrer
tochter dann die nachricht geschrieben
hallo schatz bin übers wochenende
verreist haben in deinem zimmer 100 euro
für essen versteckt du wirst sie finden
wenn du aufhörst
wenn meine schwester geschrieben hätte
ja die erfahrung hat hier schreibt ein
sohn seiner mutter papa hat mir erzählt
dass du ein neues auto gekauft hat
können wir uns das denn leisten jolo
mama weißt du überhaupt was das heißt
aber kann man noch mal so sagen oder ja
klar kann man mal so sagen
diese schalter hier schreibt eine mutter
ihre tochter irgendetwas stimmt nicht
mit meinem iphone ich glaube meine
nachrichten kommen nicht an jo die
kommen
woher willst du das so genau wissen ach
mama vermutungen und beim nächsten smsc
hat eine mutter an ihre tochter einen
witz geschickt und ihn die verschiedenen
eltern in letzter zeit auch so viele
dumme witze und die machen mit komischen
russischen hat uns später ist der mensch
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend auf
jeden fall schreibt die tochter ihrer
mutter danach kommt mama lass es sein du
es absolut unlustig und bekommt keinen
witz richtig hin aber ich habe dich
bekommen
[Musik]
das war ziemlich krank hat die schreib
deine mutter an ihre tochter bitte in
der nächsten stunde nicht an texten
liebeswirren beim sport jap hatte ich
auch eigentlich nicht vorm was habe ich
gerade gesagt und da muss ich mal ganz
kurz dazwischen haken warum sind eltern
immer so dass mein vater ist zum
beispiel eigentlich gar nicht so aber
meine mutter auf jeden fall hey ich bin
jetzt dort und dort oder ich bin jetzt
irgendwie in der kirche ich bin jetzt
einkaufen oder beim sport bitte ruf mich
jetzt nicht an stellen einfach dein
verdammtes handy aus oder willst du
jetzt jedem in einer kontaktliste
schreiben bitte jetzt mal nicht anrufen
hallo mama wir können jetzt
textnachrichten schreiben
lambert oh ja die beste erste
textnachricht aller zeiten legendär
klasse mama was heißt das lambert pro
jahr
ja
wenn sie mit lambert um toolkit sprachen
lernen dadurch wenn eine mutter im
blauen band bubble sprachen lernen wenn
eine mutter natürlich dass der himmel
sprachenlernen leider mutter dieses wort
schreibt dann meint sie auch dieses wort
wir fragt zur abwechslung ein vater mal
sein kind was bedeutet idee kyoto-2 ich
weiß es nicht liebt dich wir sprechen
später
na gut dann frage ich deine schwester
wie oft
habe ich im heutigen video geklatscht
alle dies richtig in die kommentare
schreiben die r werden die fresse du
lappen habe mich gerade mit einem freund
über whatsapp gestritten und wusste
nicht was ich in dem moment sagen sollte
und schreib einfach nur seine antwort
macarena musste lachen streit beigelegt
stark aber das muss ich auch jetzt kurz
was sagen uns was es bei mir auch häufig
so wenn ich mit irgendeiner person etwas
ernsteres gespräch hat oder so oder so
eine art streitgesprächs und wie die
wikinger wie zeigte der person hey ich
bin wirklich sauer schreibt ihr alles in
großbuchstaben und keine images oder
wie füllt man im streit bei whatsapp das
hier ist eine weihnachtsessen whatsapp
gruppe mit den mitgliedern alexander
jana mama papa und der person selbst
mama hat die gruppe erstellt und fragt
hallo ihr lieben was soll ich denn jetzt
zu weihnachten kochen hauptsache vegan
kein gluten kein weizen bloß nix mit
laktose was schreibt der vater
mama hat die gruppe verlassen
bei mir gar kein richtiges
weihnachtsessen fällt mir grad mal so
auf das sagen dass die kinder bei diesem
ball verfehlt schreibt ein vater seinem
sohn ruf mich bitte an wenn ich dich
abholen soll macht keinen unsinn und
dann ein lächeln das macht was ist das
für ein smile die je der sonos mal die
falsch geschrieben das ist der adrett
mit fliege man er macht keinen unsinn
dass
könnt auch richtig meine mutter sein und
meine mutter zb die die nutzer auch
images immer viel zu übertrieben
sie macht dann so anstatt wenn sie
irgendeine nachricht schreibt der soll
dann das schreibt sie dann geschenkt
dann macht sie auch ein geschenk ihm
ohnehin wenn jetzt zu ostern hat ja alle
möglichen eier und hasen zwei dies noch
dahinter steckt eine mutter diesen
teenager und die andere personen damen
sandra tatsächlich fragt was ein kleiner
schokokuss der auf sich aufpasst liebe
es das ist ein offen mit augen mama ich
dachte das ist ein schokokuss hh das ist
eindeutig mama wo gott das tut mir so
leid ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha hände diese
leute die so hahahaha schreiben
aber in wirklichkeit sind dabei dann so
ja ich exalead kannst du spanisch ja sag
mal was sergio ramos kassiert das
bedeutet dass ich vermisse dich ich dich
auch fernando torres was bedeutet das
ich liebe dich wo das sind einfach namen
von fußballern der ist genauso wie wenn
ich sagen würde ich sage etwas auf
portugiesisch cristiano ronaldo das
bedeutet dass bestimmt wie kann die
anzeigen wegen hausfriedensbruch hier
schreibt eine mutter ihrem sohn deine
wunderbare tante ist gerade gestorben
was ist daran komisch das ist nicht
komisch wie kommst du darauf philipp
mama heißt laughing out loud also laut
loslachen
und ich dachte es sei fertig muss jetzt
alle anrufen
oh gott oh mama blöd
[Musik]
ein tisch ist jetzt voll und joghurt
kommen wir nun allerdings zum ersten
richtigen whatsapp fälle der heutigen
episode denn nicht von einem elternteil
und einem kind stattfindet glaube ich
auf jeden fall schreibt dass dir einen
freund zu seinem kollegen r gehst du
heute haben feiern ja wirst du trinken
nein wirst du nehmen nein
wirst du es haben denke nicht warum
gehst du dann überhaupt hin dass könnten
so richtige fragen von sandra an mich
sein
allgemein finde ich sandra in jedem
whatsapp fällt hier irgendwo wieder
allerdings frage ich mich beim nächsten
wort fällt wirklich absolut gar nichts
mehr
und zwar schreibt ein sohn seiner mutter
marlen hat sich gerade ausgezogen und
rennt schreiend durch den garten war es
niklas fangen sie ein und ziehe was an
stell dir vor die nachbarn kommen raus
um zu gucken woher der lärm kommt ab sie
eingefangen und konnte sie überreden
ihre unterhosen wieder anzuziehen aber
leider nur auf links ist niklas jetzt
der bruder von marlen und mein leben
vielleicht ein kleinkind und rennt
deswegen durch den garten weil sie ein
kleinkind ist und will deswegen gestoppt
eine person vor hat gerade einen crêpe
mit nutella und kinder stiefel gegessen
aha das war bestimmt lecker ja aber sehr
mächtig war es ein linker oder ein
rechter
ja
erkenntlich ist doch total ist doch voll
die kulinarische spezialitäten von
crêpes mit einem kinderspiel aber
apropos crêpes mal ganz kurz seid ihr
eher so die leute diesen krebs und mit
zimt und zucker essen oder seid ihr so
einen teller oder seid ihr so mit
schinken und käse stimm ab hier ist eine
umfrage hat sie es nicht vergessen
sollte soll ja in 100 prozent der fällen
bisher vorgekommen sein als sich der
umfrage einfügen wollte konnten wir
allerdings nun nicht zu einem richtigen
whatsapp oder sms fail sondern mehr
einem spruch und zwar wenn in whatsapp
mama schreibt steht kann man bis zum
eingang der nachricht ruhig noch was
unternehmen einen kurzurlaub zum
beispiel und das ist die wahrheit das
ist die wahrheit also auch wenn meine
mutter ok schreiben will braucht die
dafür gefühls und drei jahre und der
nächste fällt es auch kein richtiger
feld sondern mehr eine anregung an hot
sap und zwar whatsapp sollte nicht nur
schreibt sondern auch gelöscht und fängt
von vorne an anzeigen und dass das finde
ich auch stark vor allem wenn leute da
in eine sprachnachricht aufnehmen unter
dem channel man wartet auf die sparer
niemand sonst lädt es lädt das leben ist
vorbei
dann frage ich mich immer wurde sprach
ich jetzt gesendet und hatte das
abgebrochen warum steht da nicht sprach
man schon ab gebrauchte er nimmt neu auf
oder er löscht rat seine nachricht
wieder oder du stade umfeld die ganzen
um hier er okay vielleicht weil ich so
aggressiv auf meinen tisch drauf habe
apropos sei aggressiv soeben kam eine
neue hat überhaupt nichts mit aggressiv
zu tun
allerdings kam so immer der neue podcast
folge dick und doof aus linken in der
beschreibung wir sind jetzt mit unserem
podcast folgen jeden tag habt den 15 bis
20 minuten quarantäne update von mir und
an der stelle mich dass heute wieder
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch diese episode
whatsapp fans mit mir
luca mit einem wunderschönen t shirt
dass es in die kabine
wenn der sport sagt luca gefallen hat
dann das gerne einen daumen hoch unter
dem video und ihr findet jetzt hier eine
2 die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf den
könnte main kanal abonnieren das
kostenlos dadurch verpasste keine videos
mehr so mega cool ist ein teil der look
für hu und hier ist ein anderes video
verlinkt was ihr euch jetzt anschauen
sollte denn es ist wichtig das ist ganz
wichtig klickt er jetzt drauf habt ihr
nix zu tun dass ostermontag man damit
nur um